so he was talking about like having sex
with dudes right and then uh he was like
man and then coming from the prostate is
the [ __ ] best and then I asked them
I'm like what does it feel like it feels
like the touch of God
and I was like samples though damn maybe
I should then touch me there yeah I get
your prostate milk to be down to try one
time but does it have to be with a dick
or can it be with a finger well uh you
tell me I'm hoping it can be with
fingers and is it one of those as soon
as you touch it you just bust
I think you got to get worked the first
time I'm sure really you have to work it
I think you got to get worked when you
buy a brand new a brand new lotion and
it doesn't come out of first so you
don't [ __ ] it oh I hate though that's
actually exactly what it is I need eye
contact I need lots of I love you
literally all of us are speaking from no
experience but I feel like we're on the
right track I think we should talk about
working the prostate more actually it
should normalize the work in the
prostate have you not uh is this not one
of these I like the surface of the butt